okay welcome back to the show let's get
into audience questions for the week
we're doing these a little early because
of the thanks haven't get Thanksgiving
holiday if you haven't noticed it's sort
of like a Friday show today even though
it's Wednesday even though you might
still be watching this or listening to
it on Friday I guess because of the
holiday or something in any case let's
get right into audience questions hey
David if Donald Trump is this insane and
erratic with a reelection campaign
looming in less than two years how
insane and erratic will he get once he
realizes he doesn't have to run for
re-election okay so the premise as I
understand it is if Trump wins in 2020
and then he has four years and no mo he
knows he has no more reelection he's and
he going to get even more unhinged and
erratic I actually don't think that he
will on policy but he might when it
comes to all of the sidebar repression
of media and ignoring the Constitution
and that type of thing and I'll explain
to you what I mean the reality is that
Trump has never really had hard and fast
political positions it's always been
kind of gauging the room and even from
the beginning of his presidential
campaign which I believe started with
him not really even wanting to or
planning to be President of the United
States more sort of thinking about it as
a publicity thing if he can come in
respectably second or third in the
Republican primary this would be great
for his reality shows this would be
great for the Trump brand or whatever so
he would sort of feel around about trade
were getting killed on trade and China's
beating us and then he would get a
reaction from the audience and he would
say let me do more of that because that
sort of went well but does he really
have sincerely held positions and
particularly sincerely held Republican
positions on trade not really he doesn't
even know know about it is what we
figured out he doesn't know the basics
of economics or currency or trade or any
of it he's just going to what he gets a
positive reaction for doing in front of
people
Muslim ban is another example insulting
people coming up with pet
names for them and hearing from
right-wingers about how he really
dominated he really showed those other
people it's just what he does if he
feels that it's working for him so could
he get more erratic if he wins and then
has for years knowing he doesn't have to
run for anything at the end yes but it's
not going to be on policy because that's
always just been what the crowd wants
Trump doesn't really seem to have his
strongest convictions from what we learn
about behind the scenes are about things
like he really believes three to five
million people voted illegally for
Hillary Clinton that we know behind the
scenes he continued to talk about even
when in the public narrative it was
pretty clear that it was bogus and it
was kind of going away and his voter
fraud Commission had already been
disbanded if the polls say that he's not
doing well
he wouldn't even necessarily adjust what
he's doing on that basis because he has
always said the polls are wrong does he
believe the polls are wrong I don't know
but that's the story that that he's been
telling so it's going to be very
interesting to see but I don't expect
that when it comes to policy a Trump
that has won re-election knows he
doesn't ever have to justify anything on
the basis of getting reelected again I
don't think that makes him more erratic
as far as that goes however where he
will absolutely be even more erratic and
unhinged is what you can probably guess
the more Trump believes that he could be
in trouble
we see him go nuts publicly every time
we after the fact find out Oh a judge
decided this about the Moller
investigation or he learned that this
person was set to be indicted that
correlates to lashing out on Twitter and
doing all sorts of wacky stuff and
increasing his attempts to obstruct
Trump Russia so I think that that's what
really has the possibility of pushing
Trump over the edge his biggest
hindrance is extreme narcissism and
that's what what would be most
interesting to see him deal with in a
second
which of course I hope he doesn't get
and we need to be working to ensure that
Donald Trump doesn't get if you disagree
with me if you think Trump on policy
will get more erratic if he wins
re-election let me know I want to hear
from you one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an amazing online
learning community that offers thousands
of high quality classes on almost any
topic first 500 people who click the
link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from
design video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up